c'est vrai que la part des nantais se
considèrent comme des bretons c'est un
vieux débat régional réunifier le
département de loire atlantique et la
région bretonne séparés depuis 1941 une
erreur historique pour certains
habitants l'une des premières
manifestations
c'était en 1976 à nantes plus de 5000
personnes défilent dans les rues de la
cité des ducs
cette journée de l'unité rothen avait
commencé à 14 heures au château des ducs
de bretagne par une fait qu'organiser 37
associations et mouvements bretons
d'autres manifestations suivront à
nantes des associations en faveur d'un
rattachement sont créés égale une
bretagne à cinq départements des élus
locaux y sont favorables
il faut savoir quel est le rayonnement
réel donnant donc de la loire atlantique
sur l'ensemble de l'ouest de la france
alors si nantes a véritablement un rôle
de capitale régionale et de grandes
régions à jouer je crois il faut lui
donner sa chance
les années passent et le débat est
toujours d'actualité
des habitants de loire atlantique
continue de revendiquer leur identité
bretonne comme ici en 1999 où plusieurs
milliers de personnes manifestent à
nantes
nous voulons quitter la région des pays
de la loire parce que c'est une région
administrative arbitraire
sans identité sans histoire al'inverse
d'autres sont contre ce rattachement la
capitale de la bretagne ça sera reine
les interprètes quand en 2009
le président de la région des pays de la
loire refuse d'être séparé de la loire
atlantique
ils dénoncent des motivations qui serait
surtout économique pour la bretagne
rajouter dans l'escarcelle un million
deux cent mille habitants et
accessoirement quelques financements
complémentaires c'est pas inintéressant
d'un point de vue strictement économique
qu'en tant que tel et c'est là que je
parle d'annexion voire de colonisation
c'est une autre époque en 2018
une pétition est lancée par
l'association bretagne réunie en faveur
d'un rattachement le but obligé le
conseil départemental à s'emparer de la
question
cent mille signatures sont récoltés moi
qui venais de morlaix plusieurs fois
pour récolter des signatures
c'était très gratifiant et et il faut
que les les habitants en
loire-atlantique sache que les bretons
des quatre autres départements ne les
oublie pas quelques jours plus tard les
élus du conseil départemental votre
contre une réunification
aujourd'hui non mais toujours pas en
bretagne
mais en décembre prochain pour la
première fois un drapeau breton va être
hissé devant l'hôtel de ville
[Musique]